what's more likely the narrative around
jason garrett as the giants oc will be
same old boring offense or
offensive coordinator garrett is better
than head coach garrett
i'll go with the former here just
knowing the new york giants fan base
because if he slips up at all
if we see anything that's even close to
the cowboys boring jason garrett i think
that fan base will be controlling the
narrative and be down his throat
immediately so he doesn't have a lot of
leash here and i'm gonna so i'll go with
the former when you're talking about the
narrative now what it actually will be
i
and maybe he'll have a better j he'll do
a better job now that he's the oc and
not head coach but in terms of narrative
and what people talk about i think it's
gonna be hard for him to shake what
happened to dallas last couple years
with those weapons and and the
disappointment they had year in and year
out
and i agree with you and here's my twist
on it the reality is it's going to take
some time to get the offense to where it
eventually will be football fans and
media members like to lock into their
narratives for the full season early on
and then we don't like to revisit it
because that requires effort that we
don't want to necessarily put into it
it's easier to just cling to that crutch
that we've been waving around
for you know half of the year let's go
ahead and finish the season even if
they're scoring 70 points a game now if
they become an arena football league
offense narratives will have to change
but i think that will be the narrative
initially and it's going to be incumbent
on the giants to change it but you know
with saquon barkley who we agreed the
other day is better than ezekiel elliott
and when he's healthy he is phenomenal
this could be an intriguing offense the
offensive line though is going to have
to step up and be something relatively
in the same ballpark as what jason
garrett had in dallas all right what's
more likely you got something else to
add
well i didn't know i didn't agree that
saquon barkley is is better than a zeus
elliott i didn't agree oh i don't care
okay well you said we i don't care i
just want people to know i'm not ready
to do that yet
well peter king chris sims and i all
said that saquon barkley is better than
ezekiel elliot and if you say otherwise
you're the guy who threw seven
interceptions last night playing college
football video game you have no
credibility on this topic next up
here comes the friends that's right
andy dalton
is the dallas week one starter this year
or jordan love is the green bay week one
starter next year what's more likely
um
that's a good question i would say more
likely jordan love is the green bay
starter next year i don't see
they the cowboys are gonna sign dak
right i mean there's just no way that's
not going to happen
well but the thing is and i tried to get
stephen jones last friday to address the
reality that dak prescott has a ton of
leverage 31.4 million that he's due to
make this year next year that increases
by 20 to 37.68 million basically you
have to give him an offer on a long-term
deal that gets him to say i'll trade in
what i otherwise could make year by year
over the next two years i mean this is
kirk cousins on steroids frankly cousins
made 20 and 24. this is 31.4 and 3768
with a shot at the open market in the
third year because it it skyrockets to
54.25 million to tag him under the
franchise tag for a third time so
the point is this if the cowboys don't
put enough on the table to get dak
prescott to trade in the year-to-year
approach and he chooses after that to
stay away from training camp in the
preseason and he blows through the doors
a week before the start of the regular
season like le'veon bell did in 2017.
what's mike mccarthy going to do is he
going to say well we'll go ahead and use
the guy that just showed up at
quarterback or we'll use the guy who's
been our quarterback throughout training
camp in whatever preseason they have and
that's going to be a real question for
mike mccarthy i still think it's more
likely jordan love starts week one for
the packers next year but the idea that
andy dalton would start week one for the
cowboys if dak prescott shows up five
days before week one is not ludicrous
okay yeah that's a compelling point i'll
i'll concede that it was a compelling
point i won't say that you're right but
i'll concede it was a compelling point
we'll know by july 15. and and if a deal
gets done july 15 it's all academic if
it doesn't then the question becomes
will dak prescott exercise his right
under the rules of the franchise tag
rules at the cowboys initiated by
tagging him to stay away from everything
until just before the start of the
season and still get the full 31.4
million dollars all right what's more
likely more specifically who's more
likely to pull a teddy bridgewater off
the bench this year jameis winston or
mitchell trubisky
uh that would be mitchell trubisky and i
think that that's the easy answer here
because
why why are we why are we saying that
it's totally uh done especially as a
backup i mean come on he could be a
great backup he could be the guy who
comes in with no pressure and no one's
expecting anything out of him and i
think that that's a lot of what would uh
mitch's issues have been has been
between the ears and that pressure and
and not seeing the field the correct way
i think if he has no pressure and he's
put in a situation where he has to come
in and hopefully help the team out
i expect him to be a different type of
guy and i'm not saying he's a franchise
quarterback i'm not saying he's a
starting quarterback but i'm talking
about in the situation of a backup
quarterback and being a you know taking
the pressure off of everything that's
kind of piled on in the last few years i
think you'll see a different guy behind
under center than uh you have in the
past four years
have you uh put a little scratch on
mitch trubisky at 250 to one for three
years three years
but but yeah
sure i'll do it
all right
i'll do it i think it's more like
i think it's more likely
to be now when we say pull the daddy
teddy bridgewater that doesn't just mean
play that kind that means come in and
play well uh nick foles
we have to look at his history and think
maybe he's going to get hurt and true
biscuit will get a chance i i could see
james doing exactly what happened last
year look drew brees is 41 they're
talking about restricting his throws on
thursday he doesn't have the deep ball
in his arsenal anymore uh you know one
hit for him or for tom brady is going to
potentially put them on the sideline for
an extended stretch i'm going to go with
jameis winston that's why james winston
picked that team he knows it's a chance
for him to resurrect his career playing
for sean payton and possibly getting
himself in position for the same kind of
contract teddy got from the panthers
three years 66 million all right what's
more likely tom brady and bruce arians
are kumbaya all year or we get at least
one feisty sideline interaction caught
on camera
i think by the way just one last point
about teddy bridgewater i you know
he played well but it wasn't like he was
lights out he has a pretty talented team
around him so i think the the bar to be
to get in there and and keep the ship
afloat when you have that kind of talent
around you
is a little different so maybe my answer
is james all right so this question
i think they will stay kumbaya because
bruce arians is a quarterback coach he's
an offensive coach and he is the
opposite of bill belichick and i'm not
going to say that bill belichick and tom
brady hated each other because i do not
think that's the case i think it's just
a case of
after so many years being together and
so many years of success eventually it's
just gonna have to be a split um but i
do think that bruce arians will have
a closer relationship with with tom
brady like immediately right it's gonna
be a friendlier relationship
than more of a professional relationship
that might have happened in new england
i think they will be kumbaya all season
long
yeah i agree with you and this is a
topic because it was earlier this week
that gary myers reported that there was
some sort of friction strain between tom
brady and patriots offensive coordinator
josh mcdaniels brady has rejected that
sims and i harmonized the various
threads by saying look brady was just
tired of the patriot way and josh
mcdaniels is part of the patriot way and
there is going to be friction among
members of the patriots organization
from time to time when you feel
constrained and constricted and not
appreciated for the things that you've
done bruce ariens is going to love tom
brady because he's not jameis winston
period he's on cloud nine and the other
side of it too is i don't want to say
bruce arians is in semi-retirement but
he is entrusting a lot of the duties to
his assistant coaches like offensive
coordinator byron leftwich so if there's
gonna be any friction it's gonna be
between left witch and brady it's not
gonna be aryans he's gonna he's gonna be
kind of sitting back taking it all in
and enjoying the view and watching the
yards pile up and not the interceptions
this year so i think ariens is gonna be
happy with uh with the situation all
year and brady will be happy because he
has gotten out of the patriot way prison
the thing that left him feeling like he
never was really
appreciated and paid and honored the way
that he should have been big cat i i'd
actually predict that you will see one
of those uh friction moments on the
sideline between tom brady and byron
left which for everything you just
mentioned bruce arians is probably gonna
say let tom brady make the final
decisions here let him he knows how to
run an offense he has six super bowl
rings he's gonna probably embolden both
guys which never works so that would be
where the friction happens and of course
it will not be
we'll blow it up we'll make it beat seem
bigger than it is but that's just what
happens in in the heat of the battle but
yeah bruce arians and tom brady will be
kumbaya all year or big cat consider
this it could be the byron left which is
so deferential to tom brady that brady
never gets upset left which is younger
than brady he entered the league three
years after brady and he was never
anything close
now he was good but he wasn't tom brady
from a quarterback standpoint and i
think if brady has a thought has an idea
left right's best play will be not to
push back but to say good idea tom let's
do what you think we
should hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports